a new comedy series is hitting netflix
today mike myers plays a canadian
journalist trying to uncover the truth
about the secret society of five men and
those five men are also played by mike
myers our la correspondent chris van
fleet caught up with mike to talk about
the pentavarite check it out
congratulations
you've just been kidnapped into the
world's oldest and most effective
secret society of five men i lost
counted eight is that eight characters
you play in the series characters yes
wow okay so what does the process look
like of actually getting into character
can you just
jump right into it or do you wait till
the you know the costumes on and the
makeup's on the wig zone in the makeup
chairs where the character begins the
outside in the mirror
fools the inside you know
and so for me
there are certain words too
that get me into the character when i
did linda richmond it was always the
word coffee because as a canadian i
couldn't believe that it was k-a-u-p-h-y
with austin powers believe it or not as
corny as it might be it was yeah baby
that got me into it can hardly be evil
it's just the word right i would just
say it into the mirror right right um
sometimes really
there is something rotten within the
pentameter i got a plan to get you in
what do you have to lose if you break a
story like the pen tablet you can do
something good for this world what's the
best advice that you've received in your
career mike
never give up
um
the reason you should never give up
is
great reviews is just
information
and it's just really comfortable
information
bad reviews it's just uncomfortable
information but none of it is definition
because it's a lot to ask somebody to
sit in the dark and not talk about
themselves with strangers plus ticket
plus popcorn plus diet coke
you know and i think that my
working-class parents really drilled
into me you got to give people their
money's worth
off the record is the illuminati real
yes both beyonce and jay's head are part
of it sadly that's what lemonade is
about
yes if you were to choose one of your
previous characters to join the
pentavarite who do you think would be
the best fit
i think dr evil
would be a good choice um
or shrek shrek would be a choice
so talented right there i can't wait for
that thank you so much chris the
fantabrit is streaming on netflix now jc
i know you want to see that one looks
really good